[Music]
look at the slice that's coming out oh
my gosh
the mouth full of joy that's the best
way to put it this is going to be my
wedding cake
[Music]
hi i'm kanchan koya the founder of spice
spice baby
and i love curry it's dreamy
it's creamy it's packed with spices you
can put whatever you want in it and i
think
anyone should be able to have curry
anytime they want
so today i'm going to be showing you how
to make a three-minute curry
a 30-minute curry and a three-hour curry
so let's get started
say you only have three minutes but you
really want curry with as much of the
flavor as possible
this recipe is for you it's probably
gonna offend some curry aficionados but
we're gonna be okay with that in the
name of efficiency
first we're gonna create our curry sauce
by using coconut cream
one of the things i love about curry is
the creamy texture which is kind of
challenging to achieve in three minutes
so the coconut cream instead of coconut
milk really helps us do that
we're gonna add onion powder garlic
powder and
ginger powder one of the things i love
about curry is that you get to layer
aromatics like onion garlic and ginger
and oil
but since we only have three minutes
we're just gonna hack that by adding the
powders instead
then we're gonna add cayenne for heat
then we add some turmeric
garam masala for those smoky notes cumin
and coriander powder now we're going to
add
salt to taste and some black pepper
mix this all together sure is easier
than cooking a curry on the stove for
hours
finally we're going to add our canned
chickpeas that have been
well rinsed and drained and now we're
just going to cover this
now we're going to put this in the
microwave for three minutes until it's
hot
and all those amazing flavors have had
some time to get to know each other
curry in a hurry that smells
really good so now we're just gonna take
off the cling wrap
and marvel at the fact that we just made
curry in three minutes
we're just gonna stir in some chopped
spinach so it's gonna wilt down
quicker a hit of lime juice for those
citrusy flavor notes
and then we're just gonna mix this all
together
my mom would be really impressed with
this hack
it truly smells like the real deal i'm
not even gonna lie
we're gonna spoon it onto some steamed
rice we're gonna hit it with some fresh
cilantro for vibrancy
and we're gonna taste it
this is shockingly delicious i can taste
the citrus
all the spices the different notes the
creaminess from the coconut for three
minutes
this tastes like a legit curry this is
great for busy weeknights when you want
to make something your kids are gonna
lap
up even if your indian mother-in-law
would not approve
say you want something a bit more
authentic and you have a little bit more
time
this next 30-minute recipe is just for
you
while most people are familiar with
north indian curry recipes
this particular one is inspired by
southern india
and while i'm technically north indian i
have to say this
is one of my favorites we're going to
start by warming our coconut oil
on medium heat to which we're going to
add our mustard seeds
and we're going to allow these to sizzle
and even
splatter a little bit it's going to wake
up the spices and add
so much flavor and now we're going to
toss in our curry leaves
just as those curry leaves are starting
to crisp up about 30 seconds or so
we're gonna add our green chilies the
green chili is gonna add spice
it's totally optional but come on and
then we're gonna add
our sliced onions and give that all a
nice toss
smells so good this combination
of mustard seeds curry leaves and oil
can be drizzled on your favorite salad
on soups and really on anything it is a
classic
base for most southern indian dishes i'm
going to let these onions cook down
until soft for about five minutes
now that my onions have softened i'm
gonna add a tablespoon of minced ginger
and four cloves of minced garlic
and just allow that to cook until
fragrant you definitely don't want to
burn it
once you can smell that ginger and
garlic and it smells
so good we're going to add in two
teaspoons of tandoori masala
so i'm cheating a little with the
tandoori spice blend because this
is a 30-minute weeknight friendly curry
once you can start to smell that spice
blend it's time
to add the tomatoes the tomatoes are not
just going to add a sauce but they're
also going to give us these beautiful
tangy notes at this point we're gonna
let this cook for about three minutes
and while these are cooking you may be
wondering how can this be a curry when
it doesn't have
curry powder let's talk about that we
don't really have a
thing called curry powder curry is such
a broad
concept in india it really varies from
family to family
region to region and that's why i'm not
adding just straight
curry powder to this but it's still very
much a curry
now that our spiced curry base is done
we're going to add some chopped chicken
you can do any kind of protein
like fish or you could also go
completely
plant-based and do chickpeas again we're
going to hit this
with salt pepper i'm just going gonna
toss this chicken
to get it well coated with the spice
mixture and until it's no
longer pink and then we're gonna add the
coconut milk
some tamarind paste and sugar
this is looking creamy i can smell the
tamarind
and the aroma and the smoky notes from
that spice blend
this is gonna be good we're just going
to cover this on medium heat and let it
cook for about 15 minutes until the
chicken is cooked through
it's been 15 minutes and i am just
transported back to my
childhood i can smell those spices
and the coconut and i just want to dive
in we're just gonna
spoon this over plain steamed rice
we're gonna hit it with fresh cilantro
again because that's just what we do and
because i like heat
i'm gonna do a little sprinkling of
chili powder
totally optional unless you're me a
little bit more
people think curry is so complicated but
it's
really just about layering flavor adding
a little bit of this a little bit of
that
and this is the result i cannot wait to
try it
don't burn your mouth oh
that is so good like a hug in a bowl
comfort food at its best we have the
sweetness from the little bit of sugar
we have the tang from the tomatoes and
the tamarind
we have all those smoky notes from the
spices a little bit of heat
it is really a party in the mouth so
i've shown you two pretty
quick and straightforward curry recipes
but say you want to really
up your game impress your guests this
next recipe is going to blow their minds
while our 30-minute recipe took
inspiration from the southern part of
india today we're going to be making
rogan josh a traditional kashmiri meat
curry here we have some
cubed beef to which we're going to add
garam masala spice blend
and sea salt give it a good toss to coat
the meat with the spices
garam masala is very often used in many
indian dishes particularly in northern
indian curries it has
smoky notes from clove cinnamon cardamom
bay leaf black pepper and a host of
other really mesmerizing spices
and it goes so well with any meat dish
now we're gonna brown the beef in
batches without overcrowding the pan
until it is nice and brown on all sides
coating the beef in the garam masala
really allows us to get that
layering of flavor now that my beef is
nice and brown
i'm going to take it out on a sheet pan
where it can rest
don't discard anything from the pan it
has all the flavor
and all the juices from the beef and now
we're going to use that to saute our
onions
i'm going to add a little salt to the
onions to season as i go
and to help them soften a little bit
quicker i'm just going to saute these
onions until they're soft for about 5
minutes
some people like to really get the
onions nice and golden brown
do whatever feels right for you it's all
a personal preference
our onion is nice and softened even a
little brown to that we're going to add
our ginger and garlic you can start to
see that a lot of curries have
this kind of onion ginger garlic in oil
base
in common now that the ginger and garlic
is nice and fragrant i'm gonna add my
whole spices
i'm adding black peppercorns green and
black cardamom
some whole cloves a cinnamon stick
dried red chilies and bay leaves we're
gonna saute these whole spices
with the onion ginger garlic mixture for
just about a minute
until nice and toasted and fragrant and
then we're going to add
our turmeric red pepper cumin
coriander fennel powder and some
dry fenugreek leaves sauteing the spices
at the beginning of the curry as a base
here is really
activating the flavor a lot of the
volatile compounds
and just waking up those spices so
unlike the earlier dish where we use the
pre-existing tandoori blend here we're
really building our own
rogan josh spice blend our spices are
toasted and beautifully aromatic and now
we're gonna add back
our browned beef so because spices have
antibacterial properties they were used
back in the day to prevent meat from
spoiling
almost like a pre-refrigeration
refrigeration hack
so we're getting the beef all nice and
coated with the spice mixture
and then to this we are going to add
some whipped
yogurt some people now actually add
tomato to rogan josh
for tang we're going with greek yogurt
now that the beef is nicely coated with
that spiced
yogurt mixture we're just gonna add
enough water to cover
salt and pepper now we're just gonna let
this cook
low and slow for two and a half hours
until that beef is
nice and tender and all the flavors have
merged beautifully together now that our
rogan josh is simmering away
we're gonna make roti roti or indian
flatbread is a staple in every house
while it can seem intimidating you and
me were in this together and we're gonna
figure it out so first we're gonna add
whole wheat flour
half a cup of warm water a little bit of
oil
and some salt so i'm just gonna toss
everything together
and then i'm going in with my hands so
you want to knead this
until the dough comes together and does
not stick
to your fingers if your dough is a
little sticky
just add a little bit more flour my
dough has now come together i'm just
gonna let this rest for 30 minutes
under this damp towel and we'll be back
now that our dough has rested
it's time to roll out the roti so we're
just going to take a little piece with
our hands you don't have to be super
precise here
you're going to make a little ball and
then sprinkle
your surface with flour so it doesn't
stick coat
my little circle with flour so it's
easier to roll
and then we roll roll a little bit turn
a little bit
roll turn roll
turn that should get you to a perfect
circle
if your dinner guests judge you for your
roti not being a perfect circle
i think you should send them home this
is a great activity to get your kids
involved in
sensory skill building resilience
building
because it's not going to be a circle
they're going to have to be okay with
failure
this looks great so i'm gonna set this
guy aside and roll out the rest
now it's time to cook the rotis the
trick here is to get the pan
scorching hot almost to the point where
it's uncomfortable to place your hand
right above it we're gonna place the
rotis in the hot dry skillet for about
two minutes
you want your roti to puff up but if it
doesn't don't worry about it it's gonna
taste
just as good so i'm just gonna flip it
we're gonna let this go for another 30
seconds to a minute
okay and then we're just to top it with
a little bit of butter
for extra moisture and deliciousness
that's our first roti i'm going to cook
up the rest and once that's done we're
going to be ready to bring our roti and
curry together
so our roti is done our rogan josh is
done let's bring it all together
i'm totally plating a whole red chili
because i will eat it
as always a little garnish of cilantro
so i'm just gonna go
right in using the roti almost as a
spoon
to pick up my succulent beef
rogan josh
mmm i can taste those rich and warm
spices the succulent beef the tangy
yogurt
the roti is just perfect to soak up all
those flavors
this is the ultimate comfort food three
hours may seem like a lot of time to
make a dish
but trust me this rogan josh is worth it
so there you have it three curries in
three different amounts of time we have
the three minute microwave curry for
when you want curry in a hurry we have a
30 minute curry for when you want a
really delicious meal on a week night
and then we have a three hour curry for
when you really want to impress someone
special
i hope you make them all and let me know
which one is your favorite in the
comments below
i'm kanchan and there's always time for
[Music]
curry
hey i'm alex and i love cinnamon rolls
i mean what's not to like they're gooey
they're a little crunchy they've got a
glaze
but i've got to say cinnamon rolls do
take a bit of time
and energy to make we all have different
schedules but i believe
truly that that should not mean we don't
get to eat cinnamon rolls so today i'm
going to show you how to make a
4 minute a 40 minute and a 4
hour version of a cinnamon roll let's
roll
so we're gonna start with the four
minute cinnamon roll this one is super
easy
super quick i'm gonna start with the
filling it's just melted butter
some brown sugar and some cinnamon of
course i'm starting with the filling
just so we have it done
by the time we make our dough so we've
got a little hack here because it's a
four minute cinnamon roll
i'm gonna be using pancake mix instead
of flour
because it's already got its leavening
agent in there and we can skip a couple
steps
all it takes is an egg some vanilla
some sugar some milk i'm gonna mix this
up now we're gonna add in our pancake
mix
now again this isn't a classic cinnamon
roll so don't come for me
if you want a cinnamon roll and a pinch
this might just do the trick
so our dough is looking pretty good got
a little bench flour on there and we're
gonna do a little kneading action
it's pretty cool that pancake mix works
in this i mean
a lot of people have pancake mix in
their cupboards already
once you got a smooth ball you're good
so now i'm gonna roll this
out i'm not a big measurer but we're
going for about an
eight by six rectangle all right we're
good on rolling i'm gonna start
spreading the filling over this super
easy just try to get it all there evenly
now we're going to roll this up i'm
going to try to do it pretty tightly
so we get a good swirl and then kind of
just
push it along we're going to cut this
baby in half
oh yeah that's a swirl we're going to be
microwaving
this cinnamon roll so i just greased
these to make sure they come out easy
and now i'm just gonna pop in our little
cinnamon rolls how cute
and for the final step i'm gonna pop a
teaspoon of water in here
this just makes sure that it doesn't get
too dry i'm gonna microwave these for a
minute 45
at medium power and then we'll make our
frosting
mix some powdered sugar with some milk
two ingredients in this super easy
that's a great consistency not too thick
not too thin
we're making good time i think i did
that in under 10 seconds let's go get
our rules and then
we can eat all right we've got our mugs
they're looking pretty cute
now i'm just gonna pop on some of that
glaze yes
you can't have a cinnamon roll without
the glaze four minutes cinnamon roll
there you go i mean they're looking
pretty good smelling pretty good for a
microwave cinnamon roll the last thing
we've got to do
is eat i guess you could eat this anyway
you could just eat it with your hands
i'll just go for the center i have to
say
those taste pretty good for how little
effort
they took to make the taste is there
sweet
definitely satisfying if you want a
cinnamon roll in a pinch
but if you have a little more time and
want something a little more classic
i've got the cinnamon roll for you
so this 40 minute cinnamon roll recipe
is still super approachable
but a little bit closer to the classic
so i've got my flour already here in the
bowl
i'm just gonna add all of our
ingredients so we got milk melted butter
and egg sugar baking powder
salt and for our final ingredient
instant yeast
so instant yeast is pretty cool because
you don't have to wait to activate it
like you would
active dry yeast and it's super
foolproof so pretty hard to kill
now we're gonna mix this all up so we're
looking for like a shaggy dough
you got a little more muscle in there
once it gets a little shaggier
we're ready to knead so i'm just gonna
pop this onto our surface
and get in there the dough should kind
of
come together and you'll be able to poke
it
and it will spring back our dough is
looking good
i'm gonna pop that in our bowl cover it
with the towel
and let it rest while we make our
filling all right now on to our filling
which is essentially the same as our
four minute filling we got our brown
sugar
our melted butter and our cinnamon when
i was a kid i used to like
melt butter and sugar and i would eat it
as like an after-school snack
that's why i'm like this guys it was all
that butter and sugar that i ate as a
kid
all right our filling is looking
delicious good enough for me to eat
but uh i'll wait we're gonna roll out
our dough
first we're gonna flour the surface
so again i like to eyeball things but
we're going for like
a 12 by 16 inch rectangle she's looking
beautiful we should name her her name
shall be
cheryl all right our girl cheryl is
looking
snatched we're gonna like slap on
some makeup on this girl she is going
out tonight
we're just gonna put our filling all
over there we're gonna roll it up
again i'm going for like the tight roll
because the tighter you roll your
cinnamon roll
the better swirl you're gonna have so
just take your time
there we go all right we're all rolled
up so now i'm gonna cut my dough into
nine equal pieces
wow cheryl she's never looked better
we're gonna pop these in our greased pan
it's already greased just gonna start at
the end just gonna try to squeeze them
all in here
all right they're looking great a
beautiful swirl layer in there i'm gonna
pop these in the oven at 375 for 20 to
25 minutes until
light golden brown and while they're
baking i'm gonna make our frosting we're
making a cream
cheese frosting still super easy we just
got some powdered sugar
cream cheese and vanilla so this is
going to be a little bit thicker
consistency than
the glaze was but we want it to be
spreadable
a nice creamy texture all right
delicious now we're ready to frost
damn cheryl she's looking good
so there's really again no rhyme or
reason to this i'm just gonna slap on
some
frosting you gotta get an even layer on
each
these are still a little warm so our
frosting should kind of melt down
into those swirly whirly crevices
all right we're frosty like the snowman
i'm just gonna take one of these babies
out of here look at that
oh my god i'm drooling this is more of
like your classic delicious
cinnamon roll perfect to impress your
friends to share with your friends
and really all you spent was 40 minutes
let's taste it and i think i'm gonna go
straight for the center
oh my god guys this is like heaven
mmm lots of stuff right there this
is all you need so obviously this is
delicious but if you want to see
something epic stick around for the next
one the
four hour cinnamon roll well i know what
you're thinking
how could we make a four-hour cinnamon
roll seems a little excessive
well we're making it giant now i used to
be
the queen of making things giant back in
the day
sorry alvin but today we're gonna get
even crazier
with a giant banana walnut cinnamon roll
i'm so excited i'm so excited we're
gonna start with
our warm milk melted butter
and sugar i'm just gonna give this a
stir
so our liquids are warm to about 100 to
110 degrees
because we are using active dry yeast
instead of the instant yeast
the warm temperature will help the yeast
to bloom if it's too hot it will kill
the yeast if it's too cold it won't
bloom
so i'm gonna spread it in an even thin
layer over top
just so it gets like the most surface
area so now we're gonna let this hang
out for a minute
until the yeast gets fully now i'm gonna
add in our flour
and mix this all up again we're looking
for that shaggy dough
so this is going to be a little bit of a
wetter dough than our last one
because we are doing a double proof
method this will ensure we get a very
fluffy cinnamon roll
so i am just going to cover this and let
it sit in a warm spot until it doubles
in size
it is time to make the filling for this
giant banana walnut cinnamon roll this
is going to take your cinnamon roll to a
whole nother level
all i have to do is melt the butter
brown sugar
cinnamon and a little salt so i'm
cooking this until everything kind of
cooks down
into a nice saucy kind of thing before i
add in our bananas
i'm gonna add in our bananas i love
anything banana flavored pretty much
banana bread banana cake banana cinnamon
roll
if i had a show it would be called make
it banana at this point
all right so i'm gonna let this cook
down stirring in between for about five
to seven minutes
we don't want the bananas to be
completely mush but we want to let them
break down a little bit
all right our filling is ooey it's gooey
we still got some of that chunk of
banana in there
our philly is looking good smelling even
better i'm gonna go get
the dough and we are gonna roll out this
giant
cinnamon roll all right our dough has
risen
it's doubled in size if you take a close
look you can see some of those air
bubbles in there
and that is from our yeast that
was alive good thing i didn't kill it
so to this dough i'm gonna add salt some
baking
powder and some flour so i know this is
still feeling a lot like our other
recipe but
we're about to get crazy now i'm just
gonna flip this onto our surface
and get to kneeden so the purpose of
kneading is to develop the gluten in the
dough
and that will help us get a very smooth
and elastic dough
you want a nice a nice looking dough
ball we're just gonna get straight into
rolling
so i'm gonna roll this to the same
dimensions as the last one
we're looking good we are ready to
spread our banana
filling so again we're just spreading
this out in an even layer
and now i'm gonna hit it with some
chopped toasted
walnuts banana and walnut just goes so
well together
and it's nice to have a little bit of a
crunch in here
that is looking great i need to cut this
into some strips
so i'm first just going to cut this in
half and then i'm going to cut each of
those in half
okay so to make this thing giant start
by rolling
this first strip try to again roll it as
tightly as possible so you get that
good looking swirl all right i'm just
gonna pick up this piece
and roll that into this piece
oh man okay last one
we can make it maybe a little messy
that's all right
[Music]
okay this monster
get it in there i have to say it
that's looking pretty good honestly i
would eat that straight out of the pan
right now
all right so i popped this in a 10 inch
cast iron skillet i'm going to cover it
with plastic wrap
and pop it in a warm spot to let it rise
and expand to the edge of the pan
it'll take about 30 minutes oh
man this is wild
i feel like it's my child like it's a
baby all right so i'm gonna bake this at
3 25 for 45 minutes uncovered and then
35 minutes covered in foil
blowing slow i know it takes a while but
it's gonna be worth it for this baby
all right we are so close to the finish
line i could almost taste it
but we've got one more thing to do and
that is our final frosting
of the day another cream cheese frosting
but even more decadent because we're
adding butter to this one
so to this powdered sugar i'm going to
add some milk
some cream cheese some melted butter and
some vanilla
again just going to mix this up so we
want to get this nice and smooth
so that the sugar is all incorporated
all right
frosting is done our bun is out of the
oven
welcome to the world big guy so i'm
gonna frost this thing
of course the final touch on this four
hour ordeal i have to say four hours
flew by
this is a fun thing to do beautiful and
i'm gonna top it finally with
some more of our toasted chopped walnuts
this is definitely a dish to impress and
there you have it
a four hour giant banana
walnut cinnamon roll it's crazy it's
beautiful you got the texture in there
from the walnuts
you got the gooeyness from the banana
caramel filling
you've got the cinnamon roll you got
everything
and now all that's left to do is eat
moment of truth
oh i'm speechless
it actually looks very beautiful i must
say
okay
oh my god guys this is gonna be my
wedding cake
it's perfect you get every element that
you love of a cinnamon roll
but then that banana flavor pops right
in there to say hello
and you're like where have you been all
my life 10 out of 10.
okay so we just busted out a four minute
of 40 minutes and a four hour cinnamon
roll i might have a favorite i know
you're not supposed to pick a favorite
child but if you have a favorite
let me know in the comments below if you
make any one of these please share and
tag me i'd love to see
and i am gonna go finish this thing
oh and remember there's always time to
[Music]
cook
hey guys i'm kelly and i'm a culinary
producer at tasty
and i love apple pie apple pie is the
best of both worlds it pairs that crispy
buttery flaky crust with baked spice
apples seasoned with all those warming
delicious spices but i understand that
sometimes it can seem intimidating so
today i'm going to make
a six minute a 60 minute and a six hour
apple pie
to show you that you can make this
delicious dessert no matter how much
time you have all right let's get into
it
first up is our six minute apple crisp
it's really great if you're living in a
dorm
or maybe you're having that late night
apple pie craving and you just need it
now
so first thing we'll do is just chop
this apple we're gonna cut
nice thin slices since we're cooking it
in the microwave we need to cut it
pretty small
so it cooks quickly and evenly
we're using a honeycrisp because it's my
favorite type of apple but you can use
you know whatever you like whatever your
favorite is there's a lot of good
varieties out there
okay so now all of our apples are diced
and we're gonna put them
in our mug our next step is to just add
a tablespoon of water to our apples and
all that's gonna do is help steam them
and soften them while they cook the
first time so let's go add this to the
microwave for one minute
okay so now our apples have softened so
i'm gonna add a little bit of cinnamon
brown sugar and a little bit of flour
just a teaspoon to thicken up the base
so it's not like a watery mess and of
course a little pinch of salt
so we're just going to stir this
together i love seeing the like speckled
little cinnamon bits i think it's
so pretty next we're going to make the
crumble so we have some oats
some flour more brown sugar more
cinnamon
we'll just whisk that together with our
fork and then the last thing we're going
to add
oh besides more salt sorry is
some softened room temperature butter
we're just going to mix this together
until it forms like nice chunks spread
these oats in a nice
even layer covering most of the apples
put this in the microwave for three to
four minutes until the top is golden
brown and crispy
all right it's out of the microwave it's
looking awesome you can tell all those
juices thickened up just from that
little bit of flour
and i cannot wait to dig in but first a
little garnish
some whipped cream and lastly a little
cinnamon i mean i think this is
so cute i actually think it's really
pretty it looks awesome
let's try it
the apples are tender they're full of
that cinnamon flavor
and the crisp is so crunchy honestly
this is really good but if you have a
little bit more time
and you want to make pie for more than
just yourself let me show you how to
make this 60 minute apple pie
so what i love about this recipe is it's
more close to your traditional apple pie
but it is not going to take up your
whole day to make it so first thing
we're going to do is peel our apples
make sure you have a good peeler and
your work will go much quicker
so we're using two types of apples today
we're using golden delicious and gala
apples gala
i don't know we're using those because
they're a softer type of apple and
they'll cook quicker in our pie and
save us time and then we're going to
slice them a little bit thinner than you
normally would
so in culinary school we had to practice
our knife cuts on potatoes and carrots
so i used to sneak potatoes in my bag
and take them home so i could practice
because i wanted to do the best so
that's
all of our apples now we're just going
to add brown sugar
lemon juice so they don't brown
cornstarch
to thicken it cinnamon nutmeg
and salt you never bake without salt so
we're going to toss
this all together and we're going to let
it sit while we assemble our pie crust
we have a store-bought pie crust
we're just going to roll it out a little
bit wider than
the width of our pan and that's because
we want to create
those really fun edges and we need a
little bit of length on the end
to get that so this is looking wide
enough to me
what i'm going to do is roll it up
brushing off
any extra flour along the way and then
bring your pie pan to you
and gently roll it in magically
it's in your pan press it down on the
bottom
so it reaches the edges brush off any
excess flour okay so now we're going to
add all of those apples
we're just going to put this in the
fridge while we make our top crust so
for my top crust i rolled it out to
about a 12
inch circle and what i'm going to do is
cut it in strips to make a pretty
lattice shape on top
so kind of upgrades our pie so nobody
has to know that we use store-bought
dough
so we have to make six one-inch strips
and
eight half-inch strips take your longest
piece first and place it in the middle
and this is going to be your guide
so we'll lay two of the half inch strips
in between each of the one-inch strips
pull back
each of the one inch strips and gently
place
another one in strip horizontally across
then fold the one in strips
back down over so you're going to keep
doing that process alternating between
the thick pieces and the thin pieces
until you get that beautiful lattice
design
so now we're going to do the edge so
we're going to do something kind of
different and roll it
inward tucking all those little bits in
so nobody has to see
those jagged edges we're going to start
the crimping process
so use your knuckle to like dig in and
then use your thumb and index finger to
push back
and just keep going around so now what
you want to do is just brush off any of
that excess flour
because when we add the egg wash next we
really want that to stick to the crust
and now our last step is to add some raw
sugar on top just to give it another
little crunch
so we're going to bake this in a 425
degree oven for 40 minutes
covering halfway through until the crust
is golden brown and the juices are
bubbling
let's go all right she's out of the oven
she's golden she's glossy from the egg
white i'm really excited to try it let's
dig in
i don't want to cut her because she's
too pretty
for a 60 minute pie that came together
with just a little bit of effort
the filling has tons of cinnamon flavor
the crust is super crunchy and that
raw sugar just gives it that little bit
of edge but if you have
more time and you really want to impress
your friends and family
stick with me for this next recipe now
i'm going to show you how to make my
six hour salted caramel deep dish apple
pie so first what we're going to do is
just season our flour
and we're going to add in our cold
butter i cut this in about
half inch cubes and i actually popped it
in the freezer for about 15 minutes just
so it's
really cold and firm so what i like to
do is like make sure
each of the pieces is coated in flour
before i start smashing them
toss it onto the next one also i find
this therapeutic like i can just zone
out
the kids yelling at me i can just zone
out and just keep doing my dough
okay so that is looking awesome the next
step is to add
ice water a tablespoon at a time so i
like to toss it up in the air like this
just to incorporate that water and then
add a little bit more so we're using ice
cold water because we don't want to melt
that butter
and you know that there's enough water
in it when you press together and it
holds together
so now that this is shaggy looking i'm
going to transfer it on the table
and finish bringing it all together i'm
going to wrap them in plastic and just
pop them in the fridge for about an hour
to let the gluten relax
while that's happening we'll make our
filling so for this filling we're doing
something a little bit different this
time we're going to
par cook the apples before they go in
the oven to bake so to start we have two
tablespoons of unsalted butter
melting we have a big bowl of apples
i'm gonna add them right in we have the
juice of one lemon
brown sugar salt of course so this is
pumpkin pie spice and you might be
saying
kelly what the hell are you doing but
listen to me it has cinnamon it has
nutmeg ginger cardamom so we're adding a
bunch of that okay and you might think
i'm crazy again but i'm adding a little
bit of vanilla vanilla isn't something
you would traditionally find
in apple pie but martha stewart does it
so i'm doing it okay so stir stir
we want to cook it until the sugar is
dissolved so we have a little bit of
cornstarch
and i'm just going to add some water to
make a slurry and what this does is just
incorporates the cornstarch without
lumps so crank the heat up and let it
come to a boil and then once it's thick
we can set it aside and move to the next
step
so since this is an epic apple pie we're
gonna add
even more apple flavor by reducing some
apple cider
i learned this trick from a pastry chef
where you reduce
down cider until it's the consistency of
like maple syrup
it's looking great i'm gonna let it cool
and then we will go assemble our pie so
i got my dough here it's been chilling
for an hour
now i'm just gonna roll it out until
it's about a quarter of an inch thick
all right so this is rolled out i'm
gonna do the same technique
roll it back on the pin and then roll it
back in
press it down we're going to add in all
of those apples
so i'm going to pour over that cooled
apple cider that i reduced down
this is our secret ingredient put this
in the fridge while i roll out the top
crust
all right so i rolled out my top crust
and now i'm going to add it on top and
then we'll finish assembling
press around the sides to make sure all
of the edges
are sealed together and we're going to
take a pair of scissors and just kind of
clean up
any long edges i'm gonna tuck it
under this time now we're gonna do the
same technique as before with the
crimping
we're just gonna do them a little bigger
so they're a little more exaggerated
brush it with some egg wash now we're
going to cut some slits and what this
does is help the steam
release as it's cooking so you don't end
up with a soggy top
put this in the freezer for 20 minutes
to harden back up and then we'll put in
the oven for 80 to 90 minutes until
these juices are bubbling and
thick so the apple pie is in the oven it
smells great i cannot wait but to make
it even more epic
we're gonna add a thick gooey caramel
sauce on top first we're starting with
sugar and water to make it even more
foolproof i'm going to add a little bit
of corn syrup it helps prevent
crystallization
and it will also keep that really glossy
shine that we want for the top of our
pie
now that everything is in the pot you're
going to bring it to a low boil and cook
it until it turns a light copper color
so i say caramel some people might say
caramel
caramel wait what am i saying caramel
caramel like it sounds very blunt to me
caramel
caramel caramel caramel
so this looks perfect it's like the
color of a copper penny we're going to
turn off the heat
and add all the heavy cream it's going
to boil up so don't be scared
keep stirring until all the cream is
incorporated
i'm just going to let it cool and then
we'll top our pie with it
all right guys it is out of the oven
it's beautiful
the last step is to pour this delicious
caramel sauce
over the top we're just going to let it
drip down the sides oh my god it's so
thick it's glossy from that corn syrup
the last step
is these candied pecans it is finished
it is smile high
the sauce is dripping off i cannot wait
to try this
that is some serious pie the crust is
the best part like i'm a sucker for
crispy crust and this is like
it's buttery i could just eat the crust
and the caramel sauce all right well
that is it for us
today we have made a six minute a 60
minute and a six
hour apple pie i hope you guys make them
and love them as much as i do
leave a comment below and let us know
what you think and just remember
there is always time for apple pie
[Music]
hey everyone i'm joe sasso i'm a chef
here in los angeles
and i love donuts i love how fluffy they
are how fried they are
how absolutely delicious donuts are i
think you should be able to have donuts
any time of the day in any given
circumstance and you should be able to
have them at home today i'm going to
show you how to make a 15-minute donut
a 50 minute donut and a 5 hour doughnut
all right let's get started picture this
you're hanging out with some friends you
need something sweet you're tired of
brownies you're tired of caking cookies
but you know what you're never tired of
that's right donuts first things first
we're gonna make our dredge here for our
donuts our little
sugar spice and everything nice to toss
our donuts in after they are
fried i like to start with a little bit
of sugar a little bit of cinnamon
a little bit of salt yes even salt when
you're baking
or doing something sweet it really just
brings out all the rest of those flavors
and then my little uh
secret twist to this is szechuan
peppercorn i'm gonna mix this all
together here
maybe even use a whisk make sure it's
all combined
i'm gonna set this aside we're gonna use
a little
secret donut hack we're gonna be using
biscuit dough here
there it is start with a little bit of
flour
just so we don't have any uh stickage
layout
all of our biscuits this is fun because
it's a play on
cronuts which are like croissants fried
as donuts these are biscuits fried as
donuts so they're like bow nuts
i'm gonna do them as holes so bonus
holds first i'm going to
roll these out about a quarter of an
inch here on the donuts i like to roll
them out just a little bit
i got a small hole punch here a ring
cutter because then you have little bow
nut holes
they're cute they're delicious they're
fun small foods are always cuter
and then you have these outer rings you
can bake them as biscuits
then you have biscuit rings you can put
an egg in there you can have egg in the
hole
we have our oil here 350 degrees that's
like the magical number when you're
frying things
and these are gonna go pretty fast about
three minutes on one side about a minute
or two on the other
drop them all in one by one trying to
get as close to the oil as possible
so there's not a big splash down just
kind of watch the donuts you want to see
uh
little bubbles coming off the side and
you're looking for golden brown and
delicious
gbd is what we call it in the restaurant
it's been about two minutes here we're
gonna go ahead
and flip these guys over probably got a
minute left on this last side i have my
spice mix
i have a rack here to catch my hot
doughnuts the hardest part is waiting
right now but it's only 15 minutes all
together not that bad
those are looking great we're gonna go
ahead and pull them the rack is going to
whisk away
any excess oil before we get them into
our sugar spice and everything nice mix
now the trick here donuts still hot
cinnamon sugar right away
the donuts are going to best absorb all
of this
goodness while they're hot these guys
we'll put them back on the rack
next four little toss toss smells so
good
and there you have it hot fluffy donuts
15 minutes that's awesome
what i really love about these is
they're mini donuts so you can eat a lot
of them
and not feel bad about it at all make a
basket for yourself share it with
friends one of my favorite things about
them is the szechuan
because it adds this little warming note
they're not spicy just a little
hey how you doing let's say you have a
little more time i have a 50-minute
donut recipe
that you should try
next up is a 50-minute donut little
non-traditional here
we are not using oil there is nothing
fried everything is baked in the oven
it's a maple
bacon donut first thing first we have
our bacon
onto a sheet pan i'm gonna go six slices
here
we're gonna pop this bacon in the oven
350 for about 12 to 15 minutes while the
bacon is cooking we're gonna get started
on our donut batter
we have three separate components we
have our wet we have our dry
we have our fats i like using cake flour
for this
it's very fine it's a much lighter and
delicate crumb we're gonna sift together
our dry ingredients here cake flour
baking soda baking powder and a little
bit of
salt if you don't have a sifter you can
use a whisk
combine it all together in a bowl you're
really just trying to get out all those
little lumps
and we're going to set this aside now
our wet ingredients
super easy milk vanilla together we are
going to combine our
fats uh this we're going to do in two
parts or starting with our sugar
a little bit of softened butter and a
little bit of vegetable oil now the
reason why we're doing this is we're
dispersing all the sugar with the fat
we're aerating it trapping all these
little air pockets in there so that way
when we bake
the batter the donuts are light fluffy
and delicious
creaming the butter the sugar and the
oil i like to turn the bowl
kind of getting this dual effect now
what we're looking for here
is a lighter color everything becomes
homogeneous
and a little light and fluffy almost
like fresh snow
i'm gonna take a spatula here and give
my bowl a nice little scrape down
making sure everything is evenly
incorporated
now i'm going to emulsify in my egg
again one more time with the mixer
all right now same thing here fluffy
pale in color
smooth homogeneous we'll give it one
more scrape
just to make sure we got all the sugar
everything combined
the last step here we're going to add
the dry
and the wet alternating starting with
the dry the reason we're doing this is
to not overwork the flour to make sure
there are no lumps
and to make sure everything is beautiful
and homogeneous
if we were to overwork this flour
mixture the batter the donuts will come
out dense
they'll come out a little dry they're
not going to be airy
the crumb might be a little extra tight
this careful mixing process
is going to all be worth it in the end
i'm going to add the last of the milk
vanilla stir stir stir the last of the
flour
then as soon as this all comes together
and it's thoroughly combined
we're gonna let this rest only about 15
minutes to ensure everything is
hydrated relaxed and ready to be baked
and in the meantime
i'm gonna check on my bacon bacon here
as you can see
crispy golden brown we're gonna cut this
up not looking for a perfect
dice here or just a rough chop on the
bacon course
easy quick simple no one's judging you
here
we're going to transfer this to a bowl
we're ready to start assembling our
donuts
we have these super fancy schmancy donut
pants here
if you don't have these you can use
muffin tins cupcake pants
doesn't really matter it's just going to
be a different shape they will still
taste
perfect and delicious take some
non-stick spray
coat the bottom and then i have my
rested batter
and my chopped bacon so about three
quarters of it's gonna go down into the
pans
we'll save one quarter for garnish i'm
gonna pour the batter
about three quarters of the way up it
will rise a little bit in the oven so
don't go too high here
measuring cup really helps with the
pouring i like to say work smarter not
harder
this is a great example of that and this
batter is really nice and easy to pour
i'd say it's like a little bit of a thin
pancake batter
and we have the perfect amount of batter
for 12
little mini donuts i'm going to take
these off to bake right now
325 for about 15 to 20 minutes while
they're in the oven i'm gonna get
started on my glaze
powdered sugar little bit of milk a
little bit of maple syrup
pinch of salt and we're going to whisk
this together it's going to look a
little clumpy at first what you're
looking for here is a nice smooth mix
not too thin where it's going to run off
the sides of your donuts almost like the
consistency of cold heavy cream
i think i nailed it all right we're
going to set this aside i'm gonna go
check on the donuts
the donuts are baked i've let them cool
here on a rack
down in the pans i don't want them to
dry out and overcook starting off here
getting my donut into the glaze i'm
gonna dip this in
by hand the trick is to not use hot
donuts you want these guys to cool down
if you're using a hot doughnut the glaze
is going to melt really quickly
it's not going to be a good coating give
it a little wiggle wiggle
dip dip oh baby baby i want all that
excess glaze on there because it's
yummy wiggling these guys around
donut by donut into the glaze
before the glaze settles on here i want
to get a little bit of topping action
some turbinado sugar it's like a coarse
sugar
a little bit of molasses in there for
color that'll add a nice bit of crunch
texture just sprinkle a little bit of
that on top remember that bacon we saved
that's going to go on top it's great
when the bacon falls into the center
then you got like a little bacon pocket
i'm a big fan of textures bacon salty
sweet all the good things and there you
have it our
baked maple bacon donuts i am excited i
don't know if you can tell i can't wait
to dive into it and try these things
i'm just gonna go this one here is
calling my name
this is like breakfast and dinner and
donuts and everything awesome in the
world
all rolled into one so there's no oil
these are not fried
technically a healthier donut i mean
that's science now we got
these under our belt so you have a
little more time you want to make
something a little extra
i have the ultimate donut recipe for you
now we have the five hour donut it's a
little bit more work
takes a little bit more time and
commitment but let me tell you you're
having a dinner party
people are coming over you want to show
them you're serious about life
you're serious about food this is the
donut recipe for you first things first
get our dough started i have all-purpose
flour i have sugar
i have salt instant yeast not active
yeast
then i have all of my wet i have eggs i
have buttermilk i have regular milk
i have vanilla i have a lot of things
soon i will have donuts
butter melted turning this on adding my
wet ingredients slow just so everything
doesn't fly up in the bowl
low speed till this just comes together
our dough is kneading i'm not even gonna
break a sweat doing this
we're gonna go about four to six minutes
we're really looking for a nice smooth
soft
supple dough all right it's been about
five minutes
taking a look at the dough here it's
nice and shiny
uh it is a little sticky it's a wet
dough that's hydrated it's not going to
be
a dry donut by any means i have a bowl
sprayed with nonstick i have a spatula
sprayed with nonstick and then that way
as i scrape
all of the dough out of the bowl it
doesn't stick to the spatula either
we're gonna wrap this plastic wrap set
it aside to rest
until it's about doubled in size we're
looking at one to two hours now while
this is doing its thing i'm gonna get to
work
on my cream filling this donut is filled
with a pastry cream because at the end
of the day what's a donut without a
cream filling here we're gonna take milk
heat it up very gently in a large pot
not too fast not too hard you don't want
it to burn while this milk is heating up
we have some eggs
we have some sugar some corn starch
that's going to help thicken things
along
and a pinch of salt and we're just going
to combine this
until we have an eggy corn starchy
sugary paste once your milk comes up to
a simmer we're gonna do a process called
tempering
tempering is just a process of
introducing something very hot to
something not so very hot
if i were to just take these eggs and
add it right to my milk i would have
sweet milk scrambled eggs which
maybe is not the worst thing in the
world but not for donuts
so we'll take a little bit of milk and
two hands here
whisking while slowly drizzling in your
milk
so now our eggs are warm we're going to
add the eggs back to the milk mixture
continue to whisk keeping an eye on
things making sure nothing is sticking
to the bottom
the cornstarch is going to thicken the
egg yolks are going to slightly cook and
set up
and before you know it you will have
pastry cream
take the pot off the heat soften butter
that's going to help
slow down the cooking process as well
keep things nice and creamy
i have a little bit of vanilla and then
our
last ingredient a little bit of lemon
juice
it's not going to be lemony by any means
but a little bit of acid goes a long way
we're going to transfer our mixture
through the strainer and that's really
just to ensure
we didn't really cook any of the eggs
all the corn
is equally dispersed we have no lumps
press that through and now while this is
cooling what you're going to want to do
is take a piece of plastic
the plastic is going to sit on top of
the pastry cream
prevent it from forming a skin getting a
weird texture and all that
unpleasantness we're gonna let this cool
to room temperature
we'll add my favorite ingredient rainbow
sprinkles they're fun
they're nostalgic they just make me
happy i feel like you can never have
enough rainbow sprinkles so we're just
gonna fold these little
flakes of joy into the pastry cream my
pastry cream
is ready for the donuts i'm gonna go
check on my dough and see how much it's
risen
it's been a couple of hours it's doubled
in size and we are ready to roll and cut
it into donuts
starting with a little bit of flour here
and then i'm going to turn
my donut dough out it's already done one
rise this is the point where you
can take out a little bit of anger
that's going to punch out some of that
gas
and allow it to rise a second time tiny
bit of flour on top
a little bit on my rolling pin and we're
gonna roll this out to about a half
inch thickness we're looking good i have
another ring cutter
a little bigger this time and we're
gonna cut this
into donut rounds give it a little twist
so out of this recipe we're going to get
about six to eight donuts
i'll get six nice clean ones here
and then i can bunch my dough back up
together re-roll it out
you really only want to do that once if
you do it too many times your donuts are
going to be a little dense
we're going to take a damp kitchen towel
put them to bed and let them rest until
they double in size again about another
one to two hours and i have one more
thing to work on the final component my
frosting a couple of uh simple
ingredients here we have mascarpone
cheese
we're gonna go into a stand mixer with
the whisk attachment
then i have some heavy whipping cream a
little bit of sugar a little bit of
vanilla
pinch of salt and the secret ingredient
for this
pattaya pattaya is dry dragon's fruit
pink powder it's a superfood some say it
may turn you into a dragon
if you eat it but tons of vitamins in
here i love it as an alternative to food
colorings
and dyes and just whip it together until
soft peaks
nice soft peak all right so my frosting
is all set
time to go check on those donuts our
donuts here
have risen doubled in size one last
thing left to do
we're going to fry them our oil here is
heated to the magical 350 degree
number i'm not going to crowd my pan
i'll start off with one or two donuts
here
gently lower them into the oil as to not
have them
splash and burn myself or any of my
friends around me and you can see the
donuts immediately rise to the top they
start to bubble
they're smelling delicious i can't wait
to get into these i think i could fit
one more donut in here
don't get too close you might burn your
mustache off i'm gonna let these go
about two
three minutes i could see the bottom
starting to get nice and golden
brown time to give them a flip kind of
like a little buoys push down on one
side and they'll just
float right over i'm gonna let these go
for just another two or three minutes
all right these look like they're done
i'm going to pull them out transfer them
to the rack here to cool
golden brown all around the estrogen is
nice and puffy these three are done here
i'm going to fry off the rest of them
and then it's time to assemble
the time has come i'm excited i put my
pastry cream
into a piping bag fitted with a sharp
metal tip that's going to help with
filling these donuts you're going to be
able to
poke right into the center and you can
kind of feel the donut fill up
more is good and a little bit will come
out at the end and that's how you know
you're full
don't worry things get a little messy
we're going to cover it with rainbow
sprinkles donuts are all full we'll set
this aside
and now we're going to dip into our
frosting i like to get
all down swirly in there and then if
there's one thing i always live by you
can never have
enough rainbow sprinkles don't be shy
get in there get a really really good
coating and onto our landing zone
on to the next one rainbow sprinkles
just make me happy how could you not be
and there you have it that is an
ultimate show-stopping
five-hour rainbow sprinkle donut and now
all that's left to do all i've been
wanting to do is give these guys a try
moment of truth oh there we are all of
the sprinkles
all the frosting i'm gonna go right in
there and sacrifice the mustache
it's a mouthful of joy that's the best
way to put it you get a little bit of
the yeastiness from the donut that
pastry cream filling
loaded with sprinkles the frosting get a
little bit of that taste of dragon fruit
gives it a nice kind of uh balance and
then all of the rainbow sprinkles i mean
there's nothing more
that i want than another bite of this
this is like
the ultimate bite of your childhood yeah
it is a little bit more hands-on than
the other two recipes
but totally worth all of the work and
the ultimate vehicle for eating
donuts and rainbow sprinkles and there
you have it a donut for
every occasion the 15-minute donut for
when you're craving something sweet in a
pinch
the 50-minute donut for when you don't
feel like getting out that big pot of
fry oil and then the five hour
impress your friends blow the socks off
of everyone the ultimate
rainbow sprinkle donut let me know what
you think in the comments section below
but more importantly i want you guys to
try all three at home
i'm joe sasto and there's always time
for donuts
hi i'm vanessa i'm a pastry chef and i
love cheesecake
i make it for special occasions holidays
and even if i just have some extra time
i feel like there's always time for
cheesecake so today i'm going to teach
you how to make a 20 20-minute
cheesecake
a two-hour cheesecake and a two-day
cheesecake so let's get started
first we're going to make our 20-minute
cheesecake this is perfect for
last-minute dinner plans
where you can make it right before
dinner and then it'll be set right in
time for a dessert
i've got some cream cheese here some
sugar and i have a double boiling pot
that way you don't burn your cream
cheese or your sugar
while you're melting it and we're gonna
give this just a quick stir
just to incorporate all the ingredients
while that's melting i'm going to bloom
my gelatin
by adding the gelatin to some water this
is going to activate the gelatin
and i'll i'm just going to stir my cream
cheese
and my sugar get it nice and melted
you'll see the cream cheese start to
turn
to more of a off-white that's when you
know that your sugar is melting
in with your cream cheese we're going to
add our lemon juice
our vanilla and our lemon zest the
vanilla is really going to bring the
flavor
out of the lemon and then you also want
to be able to get that fresh lemon
flavor
if you have a little bit of lumps you
can switch from a spatula
into a whisk the best cheesecakes are
nice and smooth
have a nice texture and consistency so
now we've got all of our lumps out
everything's melted and incorporated
we're gonna add our gelatin and let our
gelatin melt
i'm gonna put this in the freezer to let
it cool off okay so i've let this chill
for about five minutes
now i'm going to add our store-bought
whipped cream and fold it in
in increments you don't want to stir it
because that takes the air
out of your whipped cream so we're just
folding it in
i can definitely smell the lemon zest
you're gonna see the change in color
and you're also gonna see that your
mixture is getting nice
and light and airy and we're going to
put it into our prepared mini pie shells
you just want one big scoop you don't
want to mess with it too much because
again
you don't want the air to come out okay
so now i'm going to put these in the
freezer for 15 minutes
until they're set and then you'll be
ready to serve i love a little garnish
to really brighten up
the cheesecake so we've got some lemon
wedges here
and i'm gonna add some fresh mint i love
the color
and it's really gonna liven up the
flavor and there you have it a perfect
lemon cheesecake
for any type of social gathering or just
for yourself it's zesty
it's creamy and smooth light and airy
perfect
let's have a bite
light airy fresh zesty all the best
components
if you have a little bit more time i'm
going to teach you how to make a two
hour cheesecake
[Music]
for the two hour cheesecake it's
definitely more traditional
something that most people are used to
having it's got nice creamy texture
really thick and of course we're gonna
top it off with strawberries
for a nice presentation for your guests
so the first thing we're gonna do
is have graham cracker crumbs then we're
gonna add
our sugar just enough to sweeten your
crust
and then we're gonna add our melted
butter give it a quick stir
so everything is nice and hydrated and
incorporated
this is gonna be the crust i love that
we have the pre-prepared graham cracker
crumbs because when i was growing up
i used to have to crunch them by hand
and it was
so time consuming so now we're going to
put our graham crackers
mixture into our pie pan you want to add
just a little at a time just because you
don't want to overfill your pan
we're going to spread it out and then
you're going to start to press
with your hand all the way up the sides
you want to be firm
because you don't want it to come apart
when you're slicing your cheesecake
alrighty so now we have our prepared
crust pan we're gonna put this in the
oven on 350 for five to ten minutes
just so it's nice and firm so now i'm
gonna show you how to make the filling
you're gonna use a stand mixer or you
can use a hand mixer if you have one at
home
we're gonna add our cream cheese and
we're gonna mix our cream cheese just
for a second because we want it to get
nice and smooth
then we're gonna add our sour cream this
is gonna
really help add flavor and texture to
your cheesecake i'm gonna put this at a
medium speed just so it gets nice and
mixed up
be sure to scrape down the sides of your
bowl while you're mixing
to incorporate all your ingredients and
you don't get any chunks in your cream
cheese
and finally i'm going to add the sugar
alrighty now that our cheesecake batter
is nice and smooth we're going to add
the eggs
one at a time you want to make sure you
add it one at a time because you want
your eggs to be fully absorbed
and incorporated before you add the next
egg if it doesn't fully absorb and
incorporate
then you can get a really soggy and
ill-mixed cheesecake and no one wants
that
and of course vanilla for flavor
now that our cream cheese filling has
been mixed and our crust is set
and baked we're going to just combine
the two pour right into the pie filling
right in the middle
that looks so good super creamy texture
no lumps i love to see that now we're
gonna put in the oven on 300
for 45 minutes to an hour you want to
take it out when it still has a nice
jiggle to it
because it's gonna keep cooking as it
cools now we have time to make a
strawberry cheesecake topping so first
you're gonna take your strawberries
and you're going to put them in your
skillet you also want to add your sugar
sugar is going to help pull out the
juices of your strawberries
we're also going to add some corn syrup
the corn syrup is going to give it a
nice color and gloss
and also some added sweetness you're
going to cook this down
you still want to keep your strawberries
intact we're just making some nice
glazed strawberries of course you can
switch this out to like blueberries or
blackberries or raspberries
but strawberries are the best we're
going to let them continue cooking
we've got some water here we're gonna
add it to our corn starch
and give it a nice whisk this is gonna
make our strawberry topping
nice and thick so you can pour it and
serve it right on top of your cheesecake
so it should thicken up fairly quickly
you want to cook your corn starch until
it gets a nice glossy color again
for about two to three minutes this
looks so good
now we're ready to transfer it into a
heat-proof safe bowl
we're gonna chill it in the refrigerator
until it's nice and cool and we'll be
ready to top it to our favorite
cheesecake
all right so we have our perfect two
hour cheesecake right here
nice and set we let it chill for an hour
so we're just gonna put our strawberries
right on top
and we're just gonna spread it out this
looks so good
i love the gloss and the shine on the
strawberries the corn syrup really
helped
and there you have it a two-hour
cheesecake with a lovely
strawberry topping
that is delicious the vanilla and the
strawberry all blends in together
it's got super glassy strawberries a
traditional style cheesecake that
everyone's gonna love
stay with me for our two day cheesecake
it's indulgent
decadent and totally worth it
the first thing we're going to do is
make our dark chocolate cookie crust
take your dark chocolate cocoa powder
put it in a bowl
then you're going to add your flour and
your sugar
give this just a good mix just to get it
well incorporated
we're going to add a couple of cubes of
cold butter
you just want to cut it with your fork
getting it nice and incorporated
you want it to look almost like coarse
sand you're going to add your egg
and you're going to add your vanilla
extract these are the only liquids that
you're going to need to make your dough
and it should come together pretty
quickly you're going to add your pinch
of salt
the salt is a flavor enhancer so it's
really going to bring out the flavors of
the vanilla
and bring out the flavors of the
chocolate so once it's all
incorporated and it starts to form a
ball be sure to use a little bit of
bench flour
to dust onto your table dump
all of your mixture onto the table and
we're just gonna
knead this for a few minutes if it
starts to get a little sticky on your
table
just add just a little bit more bench
flour but you don't want to add too much
because you can dry out your dough
you know that it's needed enough when
everything is incorporated and you've
got a nice
soft ball that isn't too sticky and
isn't too tough
we're gonna wrap this up and let it
chill in the refrigerator for about an
hour
so now it's nice and set i like to use
powdered sugar to dust my surface
because it keeps your dough from
sticking on the surface and also it
keeps it a little sweet too
so we're just gonna roll it out into a
nice round so i'm making it kind of a
weird shape
but it'll work just fine you want to
measure this out into
an eighth of an inch we got a three inch
cutter we're going to cut our rounds
you're going to get about eight to nine
rounds with this amount of dough
for the crust you're gonna need about
seven and i love
making it this size and this thickness
because it cooks faster and more even
and you're able to crumble them up in
the food processor much faster
alrighty so we're gonna bake these on
350 for about 15 to 20 minutes
and we'll be back okay so i've got my
cookies nice and cool now we're gonna
put them directly into the food
processor
give it a nice little pulse
we're gonna add our powdered sugar give
it a few pulses
now we're gonna add our melted butter
and this is gonna crumble up really
nicely
so it's nice and incorporated the color
is nice and dark and now we're gonna put
it into our springform pan
note that we put some aluminum foil
at the base of your springform pan
because we're gonna put
your pan directly into your water bath
that's gonna help
set your cheesecake and cook it evenly
and just like our two hour cheesecake
we're gonna firmly press it down on the
bottom
so now we're gonna chill this while we
create our filling so we're gonna make
our caramel sauce
that's gonna go into our filling and be
a lovely topping to go on top of our
cheesecake
we're cooking our sugar on a medium heat
we're going to get nice and caramelized
you want it to melt fully so since we're
using a dry caramel which means without
water
you're going to want to stir constantly
to evenly distribute the heat to the
sugar
so it's getting nice and liquidy now and
you can see the color is starting to
change
it's starting to get to a nice brown we
want it to cook a little darker
cooking the sugar should only take about
three to five minutes total
so now there are a nice dark amber color
you're gonna add your butter
we're gonna let our butter melt we're
gonna add our heavy cream
give it a few stirs let it incorporate
and then in just a moment you'll have
some really
glossy caramel sauce if it gets too hot
while you're incorporating the butter
and the heavy cream
go ahead and turn it down to low or off
it should be hot enough for you to
continue melting the butter and the
cream
so there you have your caramel sauce so
i'm going to let this cool to room
temperature and then we're going to make
our filling
first we're going to add our cream
cheese you want to make sure that it's
nice and mixed up
before you add any other ingredients or
it's going to get really chunky
then you're going to add your sour cream
next we're going to add our sugar
so now we're going to add one at a time
our eggs you want to have that
nice off-white golden color next we're
going to add our vanilla
and our white chocolate you want to make
sure that your white chocolate is melted
to room temperature
too hot and it's going to cook your
cheesecake too cold it's going to seize
i add white chocolate because it really
adds a nice full
flavor makes it really decadent and rich
so we're gonna divide everything into
these two bowls
we're gonna put all of the chocolate
same as the white chocolate we melted it
at low power
and then we're gonna use only half a cup
of the caramel we're going to save the
rest to put as a topping
then we're going to take two cups of the
filling and put it in each of the bowls
it's okay if they're not completely
leveled we're doing this because we're
dividing it into three layers so we have
a nice three layered cheesecake
so let's incorporate the melted
chocolate into the cheesecake
batter and now we're gonna stir our
caramel
the difference between caramel and
caramel is that caramel is a sauce
caramel is a candy some people use them
a little interchangeably though
look at that pretty color i love this
color
so now that looks nice and incorporated
we've got our spring form pan and we're
gonna layer
our filling we're putting the chocolate
in first because it has the most density
and we're going to smooth this layer out
nice and even in our springform pan
now the next two layers you want to make
sure you pour slowly
that way it settles on top and it
doesn't zebra in
and mix in with the other layer you can
even kind of
pour it on top in a circular motion so
we're just smoothing it out
not to put too much pressure on the
batter and then finally we're going to
add
our top layer which is our white
chocolate layer again you kind of just
want to pour it on top and around
and so we're just going to smooth this
out just so gently
now that it's all smooth i'm going to
put this in a water bath you want a nice
pan size that's going to fit the entire
cheesecake
place it into here and then you're going
to get some hot water
and you're going to pour it just about
one third to one half of the way up this
helps cook your cheesecake more evenly
and also it's going to keep it from
forming a dome and cracking so we're
going to put this in the oven
on 300 for about two hours and then once
it's all cooked through
you're going to put it in the
refrigerator overnight and you need that
full chill
all the way through so you can slice it
perfectly and it sets really nicely
okay so now we're gonna make candy
pecans i like to do this on the first
day that way you can get it out the way
let it cool and set
ready for day two and you can put it as
your topping we've got our
water here we've got our sugar
and we've got some corn syrup this is on
a medium-high heat
you don't want it too hot because you
don't want to cook your sugar too fast
you want to cook your sugar for about
three to five minutes once you get a
nice glossy color
you can add your pecans this time you
really want to stir this
constantly make sure you kind of keep
them separated so they don't stick
together too much
once your pecans are nice and coated and
glossy
we're going to take a parchment lined
pan
and you're just gonna pour it right on
the sheet be sure to separate your
pecans out while they set
take your cheesecake out of the oven put
it in the refrigerator and then take
a nap you deserve it we'll come back on
day two
and finish off our cheesecake
all right so it's day two i've removed
the cheesecake from the foil and the
water bath
it's nice and set and you're just gonna
pop it open right from the bottom it
should come right out we have melted
our chocolate and we've also just
reheated
our caramel from yesterday first you're
going to drizzle the chocolate
you want to do like a zigzag and you
want to make sure that the consistency
is liquidy but also thick so it holds
you add your
pecans it looks so crunchy so crispy
i'm going to use all of these there's no
such thing as too many pecans and then
once you've topped it with your
pecans you're going to seal it with your
caramel sauce
this time i like to do it the other way
to give it a nice pattern that looks
so good
okay so there you have it you've got
your two-day
cheesecake your friends are gonna be so
impressed
i'm gonna give myself a very healthy
portion
look at the slice that's coming out oh
my gosh
so pretty dig into all these layers
[Music]
totally worth it you can totally taste
all the flavors with the white chocolate
of the vanilla the caramel
the chocolate the nice bitter crunchy
crust it's so sweet
but it's super balanced that's what i
love about it it's not like an over
sugar block of cheesecake it really is
a perfect level of flavor so this was
wonderful and delicious
i really hope you enjoyed making all the
different cheesecakes we made a
20-minute lemon cheesecake
a delicious quick and easy two-hour
strawberry cheesecake
and of course the wonderfully decadent
two-day
turtle cheesecake let me know which one
was your favorite in the comments below
and don't forget there's always time for
cheesecake oh
[Music]
yes
you